[Music]
a mobile task force makes its way
through the siberian forest snow covers
the trees the only light comes from the
moon shining through the branches the
commander holds up a hand signaling the
team to halt in a small clearing in
front of them is the creature they've
been searching for it appears to be part
deer part human the creature howls in
pain as it rips the skin from its body
the scp agents watch it in horror as the
creature reaches its arm high into the
air and plunges a knife into its stomach
it doubles over in pain and stops
screaming the creature pulls the knife
from its midsection and stands upright
blood splatters across the shimmering
white snow it turns towards the mobile
task force and slowly walks towards them
help me the creature whispers i need you
to save me from what's inside it
collapses to the ground the mobile task
force secures the creature in a
containment vehicle in preparation for
further examination this is scp-1068-ru
shell of god when they arrive with the
creature to an undisclosed scp
foundation site location dr belkov is
put in charge of learning more about the
entity when scp-1068 first awakens in
its containment chamber belkov is
watching from behind a two-way mirror
the creature walks up to the mirror and
examines the countless scars and
stitches that cover its body
scp-1068 shakes its head and gingerly
runs a long finger along the fresh wound
where it stabbed itself earlier it
glances around the room as if looking
for something then turns back towards
the two-way glass what time is it it
asks its reflection dr belkov knows that
the creature is talking to him it may
not know who is watching him but it
knows there is someone there dr belkov
pauses for a moment what harm can it do
to tell the time he thinks belkov pushes
the intercom button and speaks you've
been in there for almost 6 hours he says
into the microphone
scp-1068 looks startled its eyes open
wide as it scans the room again you need
to let me out of here it shouts quickly
or you will all be in danger the
creature starts to bang on the glass
causing dr balkhoff to take a few steps
back there is fear in its eyes that
terrifies the doctor belkov tentatively
walks back towards the intercom button
and pushes it i'm not sure it'd be safe
to let you out quite yet my friend why
don't you tell me what's going on there
is no time
scp-1068 screams i
i can feel him coming just as it
finishes the sentence as cp 1068
stumbles backward dr belkov looks on in
horror as the creature's stomach begins
to expand as if something is pushing on
it from the inside a set of claws rips
through its skin from within warning
lights begin to flash in the observation
room the temperature around scp-1068 has
plummeted the fluorescence in the
containment chamber start to flicker the
howls of the creature are accompanied by
the screeching of something else
whoever's trying to crawl out of
scp-1068
is fighting hard to complete their task
scp-1068 swings the knife tied around
its wrist into its hand it begins
stabbing at whatever is trying to burst
out of it causing blood and skin to be
thrown across the room the creature
opens its mouth and lets out a cry of
pain this goes on for several minutes
before whatever is inside
scp-1068 retreats back to where it came
from
scp-1068 stands in the room panting it
opens the satchel at its waist and pulls
out a bone needle and string it
meticulously begins to sew up the wounds
from the knife dr balkov watches panic
fills him as he slams the intercom
button what the hell was that he asks
that my dear friend was my brother with
those words hanging in the air dr belkov
furiously jots down notes he needs to
learn more velkov runs out of the
observation room and grabs two scp
agents to accompany him into the chamber
of scp-1068
he needs to examine the creature and
find out what is going on within it when
dr belkov and the two agents enter the
room scp-106 shows no signs of
aggression although the creature has a
masculine voice its chest and other
human parts seem to be female its entire
body is covered in stitched up wounds
however dr belkov can see into one of
the fresh punctures that scp-1068
made to itself the creature looks at him
and shakes its head you have no idea how
much danger you are in it says we want
to help you my name is dr belkov and i
work for the scp foundation can i
examine that wound
scp-1068 looks at the doctor considering
his question i have nothing to hide but
be aware you might not like what you see
dr belkov nods his head he holds up a
flashlight and shines it into scp-106
wound what he sees gives him pause there
are no bones organs or muscles of any
type under the creature's skin the space
inside the body seems to be infinite
perhaps it is a deep void to another
dimension belkov thinks as he gets
closer to the wound he can feel a cold
breeze leaving
scp-1068's body do you mind belkov asks
while holding up a thermometer the
creature shrugs indifferently belkov
tries to take the temperature just
beneath the creature's skin but it is so
cold that it causes the mercury in the
thermometer to freeze the doctor
furiously writes notes into his log as
cp 1068 finishes stitching up its wounds
the creature sits back in its chair i'm
sure you have some questions let me
start by introducing myself i am i neil
i come from an ancient tribe that
inhabited the area where you found me
many moons ago so you've been around for
a while belkov asks that is correct i
lived with my seven brothers and a small
tribe of humans deep in the siberian
arctic my brothers and i were wiser and
more skilled than anyone else in the
tribe who eventually became deities to
them i was the patron saint of
seamstresses and a warming shoulder for
the people unfortunately not all of my
brothers were kind i think i see where
this is going says dr belkov in my
experience there is always one who
betrays the rest when it comes to beings
with special powers you may be more
right than you know says i kneel shaking
his head for a long time there was peace
and harmony but then the great grief
happened my brother whom i will not
speak the name of was the master of the
hunt he believed that since he provided
life-sustaining sustenance for everyone
he should be the ruler of the tribe i
was the closest to this brother so he
asked me to join him as his
second-in-command i refused i assume
that probably didn't make him too happy
says belkov no it did not he was furious
and slaughtered everyone in the tribe
including the woman and children then he
began to kill his own brothers he
butchered our whole family and then
eventually came for me too i could not
match his combat skills but i had a plan
we battled for many nights i waited for
the perfect opportunity and when my
brother lunged at me in blind rage and
frustration i knew it was the moment i
was waiting for i ripped open my stomach
and he fell into the void oh i think i'm
going to be sick gag spelkov are you
telling me that thing inside you is your
brother that's exactly what i'm saying
says i kneel how long has it been in you
ask spelkov too long that is why i have
sought the help of the scp foundation my
brother cannot escape otherwise the
whole world will be doomed dr belkov
leans back in his chair and whistles he
can't believe what he is hearing but at
the same time this wouldn't be the
craziest thing he has witnessed at the
foundation now you must leave the room
says i kneel it's almost time for my
brother to try and escape again it
happens every six hours and if i do not
stop him he will destroy us all dr
belkov and the agents leave the room
once the door is closed i neal begins to
scream he looks down at his stomach as
his brother rips through his insides an
audio recorder in the room picks up a
conversation between i neil and his
brother as they battle they are talking
in their native language several days
later dr belkov retrieves the audio and
sends the recording to the linguistics
department to be decoded for several
days dr belkov watches i neal battle his
brother every six hours the brother rips
through the stomach lining of scp-1060
with its claws i neal stabs him using
his knife and after the bloody battle is
over i-neal sews himself up and rests
until the next attempted escape dr
belkov sits in the observation room
flipping through his notes when he comes
across a report from the linguistics
department he had forgotten all about
the recording but he reads the
translation his heart sinks what in the
name of god he says out loud the
conversation that was recorded during
the battle didn't make any sense a
muffled voice could be heard saying
thinking
because of your selfishness we will all
die
the cycle must not be broken
let me be
reborn this was clearly the pleading of
i neil's brother but it is the next
words that truly terrify dr belkhoff
they believe your lies
isn't that enough for you
the next sounds that the recorder picked
up were the stabbing of flesh and
screams of pain dr belkov shakes his
head so i neil is lying about something
belkov thinks could he be evil perhaps
the characters in his story were
switched what if i neal was the one who
slaughtered before he can finish his
thought there is a loud crash as the
two-way mirror shatters standing in the
opening is scp-1068
his eyes have changed now they are
filled with evil oh doctor i'm sorry it
has come to this but i can't let you
live when you are so close to the truth
says i kneel the creature steps through
the opening into the observation room dr
belkov screams as the knife plunges into
his stomach now watch
scp-2273 major alexey belatrov scp
animation or check out scp-610 the flesh
that hates scp animation